so when you look back at your incredible
career what do you think of in terms of
what you'd wish you'd spent more time on
less time on you know how some people
say you know I wish I'd worried less or
I wish I'd reached out to this person or
that person anything that you can think
of now that you think yeah I wish I'd
done less of this I wish I did unless
whoever it was a mindset oh well yes
certainly when I was it's not that I'm
not serious now but I was so serious
when i first started which is a good
thing but there were certain things that
i passed on because in my young mind it
wasn't serious enough and it was it was
a huge mistake because there was a great
experience there to be had it isn't
isn't always about the quintessential
part or anything like that so in that
way I wish that I had taken it just
slightly less seriously in terms of what
you'd wish maybe you've done more of
anything a theater and and you know and
hope to hope to do more theatre i wish
i'd stayed i did some theater in new
york i wish i would have stayed to do a
little bit more before but I'm a
California girl it's hard I wanted to be
I wanted to be home so I came back
you